what have you learned since being
friends with Douglas how's he impacted
you or influenced
you well douglas douglas is very very
disagreeable you know and he enjoys
combat and that isn't something that
really characterizes I don't enjoy
combat at all I mean part of the reason
that it's perverse I suppose in some
ways part of the reason that I will
engage in
difficult conversations is because I
don't want to have them
forever and so you know one of the rules
I had in my marriage and it was a rule
that my wife also was pleased to follow
was that if we have a problem we're
going to deal with it right now and
we're going to deal with it right to the
bottom and that's very unpleasant but if
you do
it sometimes you only have to do it once
and the problem goes away and then you
don't have that Bloody problem every
every day for the rest of your life and
sometimes it takes you know 20 times
before it's fixed before you've got to
the bottom of things and that can be
very
unpleasant Douglas is very very good
at not letting people off the hook he's
very tough and he's very good at
defending himself
and there's a pitilessness about him
that's extraordinarily admirable it's a
judicious pitilessness you know and it's
a dangerous game to play because there's
another gospel realization let's say is
the standards you judge other people by
will be the standards that you yourself
are judged by and the reason for that is
well how are you going to judge everyone
else and not apply the same standards to
yourself like that's not going to happen
because you become what you practice and
you'll turn the eye the Hostile eye that
you turn on others you will absolutely
turn on yourself there's there's no way
around that and so Douglas plays a
dangerous game because he's very
combative but he's also extremely
careful he's very careful with his words
and we've had a he toured with me
through Europe I think we did nine shows
together we we split the Q&A he intro he
did a little bit of an introduction
before my lectures I really liked it I
thought it was great it's been a
privilege to get to know him super sharp
um very cultured person um very witty so
he has a great sense of humor which is
also fun which also is one of the things
that makes him a very dangerous opponent
in a debate because not only does he
have the facts at hand like Bjorn
lomberg but he's devastatingly witting
witty and cutting and it's fun to watch
that he's a master at it so it was uh
it's interesting to think about the fact
that all you need really in a live
debate I think I I learned this from you
and Sam ages ago if you're doing a live
debate now that's not a proper
intellectual formatted opening remark so
on and so forth if you manage to get
sort of two or three real zingers you
won regardless of the content if you do
two or three real Zinger whole crowd
laughs guess what you you got yeah well
the great public intellectuals have a
vicious sense of humor right and I mean
I also think that's why so many of the
successful podcasters have been
comedians
well at the ark conference I think
Constantine Ken's speech was the
overwhelming hit of the convention I
think it's got 600,000 views as of today
650 on the ark side and about 600 on his
own channel and Constantine did a
beautiful job of merging intellectual
content with wit well the thing the
interesting thing about uh my live tour
that I'm about to start doing bunch of
my comedian friends have said to me dude
I am I am so jealous of the tour that
you get to do because no one's expecting
you to be funny if you managed to be
funny four times in 90 minutes you've
killed if I'm not funny once every seven
seconds I'm a comedian right right
so the bar is set and obviously coming
in with Constantine's background of
Comedy means that he is able to be by
far the you know Far and Away way
funnier than most public speakers uh but
doesn't get held necessarily to the same
standards that he is not expecting to be
one liners all the time one of the
things that Douglas brought up when you
guys were talking on stage that I
thought was particularly interesting was
The Perils of smart people getting
captured by culture wars do you
ever think about how much time over the
last decade some of the smartest people
on the planet have had their attention
their cognitive horsepower just yeah
taken away arguing about whether men or
men and women are women or not or
whatever the idea the jure of the day is
is yeah well this is something so I've
been partnering with the daily wire for
about a year and a half so far that's
been very successful they've been a
pleasure to work with but what they
wrestle with constantly all of them all
of the principles all of the principles
at Daily wire would rather in some real
way be be concentrating on philosophical
theological or dramatic matters so which
is partly why the daily wire is turning
towards entertainment for kids but also
for adults starting to make movies for
example and TV shows they'd rather be
doing that I had Ben
Shapiro um he participated in this
seminar on Exodus that I produced with
about nine other um extraordinarily
interesting thinkers and Ben is Shawn
you know he he's he's
wasted is he wasted on the
political the political is necessary but
it's it's one nation under God for a
reason because the political the
political isn't the Pinnacle never it's
never the Pinnacle and if you're capable
of discourse at the Pinnacle political
discourse is secondary it's also
evanescent right there's ways that it
can tumble as well there's uh how would
you say degrees of depth of political
stuff too because what works on YouTube
a lot of the time is in reacts to insane
woke Tik Tok or does whatever and it's
easy to get pigeon H hold that way yeah
yeah and it is is it a
waste it's nonoptimal but it's a
question it's an interesting question to
be asked right about how much sort of
ankle or skirt or need you need to show
from an algorithmic perspective in order
to keep the numbers churning because
ultimately you're producing what people
click on you don't want to be completely
beholding to your audience that's
audience capture but you also don't want
to be so unaware of having your finger
on the post of what is trendy that you
become obscure and obsolete right right
well in and that well in that line that
you're trying to walk when you're
dealing with matters that are the
highest and also making them publicly
accessible that's a very very tight line
to walk I mean Jonathan Paso has done a
good job of that although his Market is
still relatively Niche and he certainly
is more esoteric let's say than the
daily wire guys who tend to devolve into
the political and that devolves into the
cheap political from time to time right
the hit for hit sake or the or the
chasing the algorithm and I mean that's
the danger that all politicians have too
is that and I've seen this with lots of
political types who have developed a
Persona this is particularly true in the
United States I would say because
Americans are so salesman and I don't
say that dismissively it's really hard
to sell to Market to communicate
I I saw the Elvis movie recently and I
thought it did a beautiful job of laying
this out because Elvis was a stellar
talent but his manager who was a real
Shyer was also a stellar Talent like
Elvis wouldn't have been who he was
without his corrupt manager and you know
it's sort of a deal with the devil but
you have to give the devil is due too
and the salesman part of American
culture can easily devolve into a kind
of
narcissistic manipulativeness that
that's where it would go if it becomes
pathological but as you said you have to
be aware of your audience and you have
to be delivering what there's a market
for and it's very difficult to get those
things right we'll get back to talking
to Jordan in one minute but first I need
to tell you about Maui Nei venison Maui
Nei venison is the most protein dense
and nutrient-dense red meat on the
planet thank you plus they're the only
stress-free 100% wild harvested meat
available
my favorite method for cooking it is
straight from Frozen salt the hell out
of both sides 12 minutes in an air fryer
at maximum temperature turn it over 12
minutes again and it is perfect every
single time it is such a life hack
actually taught to me by Jordan's
daughter Michaela and all she does is
eat meat so that's the way to do it all
of the cuts are spectacular but their
venison sticks have been my new favorite
while I've been traveling on the road
you can get the healthiest red meat on
the planet delivered directly to your
door by following the link in the show
notes below or going to Maui venison
docomo wisdom using the code modern
wisdom at checkout that's 20% off by
going to M AI nuui venison docomo wisdom
and modern wisdom a
checkout thank you very much for tuning
in if you enjoyed that clip with Jordan
you will love the over 3our long podcast
episode which is available right here go
on give it a tap